fundamentally the idea is this so we
have the vocabulary with which we
describe our position these are the
reality right so we wonder for instance
what relation is between a human and a
nonhuman animal between organisms and
inanimate matter etc meaning we're
looking for a place in nature because
it's not obvious what our relation to
the universe is now I think of the human
mind as just this vocabulary that is the
language that we use and the modes of
thinking the concepts that we deploy
when trying to figure out how it comes
that we don't merely blend in with
non-human reality and that capacity
invokes further vocabulary such as
intentionality that is our capacity to
think about something that is not itself
a thought etc and if you look at the
truth conditions that is the kinds of
things that you say about reality
including your position in it and what
it is for these statements to be true or
false you'll soon notice that you're not
talking about the brain and not even
about an animal well for instance and
the nests of bosons and unknown the
universe the origin of the universe the
curvature the degree of curvature of
space-time around the Sun and so forth
so a lot of the a lot of the things that
natural science discovers and refers to
are part of non-human reality the human
animal the human organism notice is
itself part of non-human reality because
the fully human activity includes our
capacity to think about reality and the
capacity to think about non-human
reality is to say the least not in the
same way part of non-human reality as
saved our brain or the mass of
the known universe when I talk about the
world I mean you know absolutely
everything and the history of the entire
universe from its beginning to attend or
if you think that their numbers the
history as abstract objects then the
history of the universe plus all the
numbers right so whatever you think
there really is the idea of the world is
the idea of all of this being part of
one total domain and so I argue in the
book why the world does not exist and
elsewhere that it's impossible in
principle for such a thing to exist just
to give you a flavor of how the
arguments run and what triggers them you
know
so imagine existence will be the
following fact that something is part of
the world right I mean I'm part of the
world you're part of the world we both
exist so it's plausible to think that to
exist just is the following to be
included in the world right in the world
plus you write a list of the things that
exist and that's just basically a map of
the world a road to reality right so
this would be one way of thinking about
this but now ask the following question
does reality itself or does the world
itself exists if the world itself it
exists then the world has to be part of
the world but how can the absolute whole
of which everything is apart be part of
itself well good luck figuring that one
out what we often mean by analytic
philosophy is something like this you
argue for a view on the basis of known
facts or accepted logical systems or
something like that right and what
people often mean by continental
philosophy outside of the continent such
as here on this island is whatever weird
things people are doing in France and
Germany or another prominent way of
drawing the distinction is suggested by
John Searle who says if you ask an
analytic philosopher question you get an
answer with an argument if you
continental philosopher a question you
get a name so an analytic philosopher
and that idea will say well I believe
such and so for the following reasons
whereas the continental philosopher will
say Hegel said such and so now this is
obviously false because
eggle doesn't say Hegel says such and so
Hegel gives you arguments for views so
if this would entail that Hegel is an
analytic philosopher and a Hegel scholar
is well sure but a Hegel scholars a
Hegel scholar and needn't even be a
philosopher so I think that the term
analytic philosophy picks out at best
just philosophy so if there is
continental philosophy it is analytic
philosophy so I don't see where the
distinction would lie often there's a
perception that there is such a
distinction because english-speaking
philosophers English native speakers
read German and French books from the
past in translation and the translations
are willfully obscure because the
translators are often not competent and
really competent in the language so you
read Heidegger or Hegel or cons or
Sartre in the English translation or
door no and this whole thing reads like
you know willfully of obscure expression
of confused ideas but that's just a
problem of translation so at the end of
the day I think there's absolutely no
substantial division I mean at the
beginning of so-called analytic
philosophy there were ideas that no one
sticks to in philosophy anymore namely
the idea that analytic philosophy means
he give the conceptual analysis of a
given concept such as knowledge into
components so that you have a
substantial definition of something but
that's not what people are doing anymore
so at the beginning of so-called
analytic philosophy it might have looked
much more than today
that there was such a distinction but
even then this was an illusion right
well I think I was invited to an earlier
version a couple of years ago I think
two or three years ago and then I looked
when I got the invitation I looked at
the marketing of the festival and it
turned out that you know like ever since
its inception it always had like an
extremely impressive scientific and
philosophical lineup so I immediately
accepted the invitation and I'm glad to
be back for the second time but so yeah
I was invited and then I looked it up
and it was so impressive that I
immediately accepted the invitation yeah
so what's specific I think about this
festival is that it is really
substantial science and philosophy so
it's not just you know like an
intellectual conversation about the
problems of our time that's important
enough it's really about people being
together and trying to figure stuff out
so when I'm here I you know I'm
constantly an extremely substantial
philosophical conversations and that is
not necessarily the case that all ideas
festivals often it's really much more
about the production of the impression
that one is thinking whereas here I feel
like people are really doing something
it's a substantial contribution to
enlightenment
that's really great and relax a truth
the good thing it's true yeah get your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival at how the light
gets in aaaggghhh